RECORDINGS BEING MADE OF
TODAY'S PROCEEDING IS ALSO
BEING TELEVISED. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ATTENDED THIS HEARING
MUST WEAR A MASK AT ALL TIMES.
ATTENDEES MUST ALSO REFRAIN
FROM CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
DESTROYS MPC ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
HIS HEARING. VIOLATIONS OF
THESE RULES VERY SUBJECTIVE
INDIVIDUAL TO REMOVAL OR OTHER
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS. MISTER
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY HERE CUNNINGHAM HERE
SENATE. FLORA GIPSON LEE YEAH
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS RAMOS RUBIO
VOEVODA WEBER WE HAVE
WE HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVE A
CONSENT AGENDA. KALRA THANK
YOU. MISTER CUNNINGHAM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED MISTER CHAIR I WOULD
VERY RESPECTFULLY REQUEST MOVE
ITEM FIVE H. R. SEVENTY FOUR
FROM CONSENT. OKAY OF WILL
REMOVE ITEM FIVE AS REQUESTED
BY THE VICE CHAIR IS OUR MOTION
ON THE REMAINDER OF THE CONSENT
AGENDA. SUCH MOVE BY MS RUBIO
SECONDED BY MR GIPSON. OF MR
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY. AYE COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CONSENT CUNNINGHAM
HI SENATE SENATE ARGUE FLORA
GIPSON FIVE GIPSON HIGHLY WE
AYE MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS RAMOS RAMOS I RUBIO
RUBIO IV PURA WEBER WEBER HI
OKAY IS OUR MOTION I DON'T
NUMBER FIVE H. R. SEVENTY FOUR
POINT ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER IN
FACT MOVEMENT FROM SECONDED BY
MR GIPSON A MISTER ACTOR PEACE
CALL THE ROLL COOLEY HI. COOLEY
AYE CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM NOT
VOTING. HI BENNETT BENNETT HI
FLORA GIPSON GIPSON HI LI LI I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS RAMOS RAMOS I RUBIO
RUBIO HIGH VIA FOOD LAW. HI
WEBER WEBER HI THE MOTION
PASSES WHAT. MOTIONS PASSED
AND- I WILL REMAIN HERE FOR A
MINUTE AND CASES THOSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- SO- VIA BRUTAL
HIGH ON CONSENT. VAPORUB
HIGHLAND HR. SEVENTY FOUR. YES
WHY. I THINK WE CAN ENTER. WE
WILL ADJOURN THE MEETING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH